hi guys my name is victor welcome to my
diy time channel
today i'm going to show you how you can
program smart key for your nissan or
infinity car
right now i have only one key for my
nissan altima and that's a very
dangerous situation
if i would like to make a copy of my
smart key it would cost me about eighty
dollars
but if i lose my one and only key i
would have to tow my car to the dealer
and pay them up to six hundred dollars
to make a brand new key
it's very easy to lose your key and
that's happened to me in the past
once i was fishing and i accidentally
dropped my key
it fell between the cracks into the
water and it was gone
luckily i had the spare key for that car
and my wife brought it to me
and that's why you want to make a copy
of your smart key as soon as possible
to program second smart key for my car
i'm going to use this programming kit
made by dorman
it cost me around 80 and if you're
interested you can check out the link
for this programming kit
in the description area below
this kit includes brand new generic
smart key fob
it resembles original key except it
doesn't have infinity or nissan logo
next we've got the programming
instructions
and there's also the programming device
now let's take a look at how to program
a spare key using the instructions
provided with this programming kit
first we'll need to activate the
programming mode in your car here's how
we're going to do this
step 1 get inside the car and close all
doors
insert your original fob into the key
slot on the left side of the steering
wheel
step two without pressing the brake
pedal push the start stop
engine button once and then press it one
more time to turn on the instrument
cluster
step three insert the programming device
into the obd2 port in your car
the programming device will beep two
times
step four wait for at least 10 seconds
and then press stop engine button to
turn the ignition off
the programming device will beep one
time
step five wait for at least 10 seconds
without pressing the brake pedal
push the start stop button to turn the
ignition on
the programming device will beep two
times
step six wait for at least 10 seconds
and then push the stop engine button to
turn the ignition off
the programming device will beep three
times
step seven wait for at least 10 seconds
and then without pressing the brake
pedal
push the start stop button to turn the
ignition on
and then you should see a red car light
flashing on the instrument cluster five
times
this indicates that your car
successfully entered the programming
mode
now we are ready to program your brand
new key
step 8 remove the original key from the
key slot
and then insert your brand new key that
you're trying to program
step 9 without pressing the brake pedal
push the start stop button to turn the
ignition on
you should see a red car light flashing
on the instrument cluster 5 times
your brand new key should be programmed
now if you'd like to program
additional keys repeat steps 8 and 9
for each additional key and now as a
final step
we need to exit the programming mode
step 1
push the start stop button to turn the
ignition off
step 2 without pressing the brake pedal
press the start stop button to turn the
ignition on
step 3 push the start stop button to
turn the ignition off
step 4 remove the programming device
from the obd2 port
and finally step 5 start the car test
your new key fob
and make sure that all of the buttons
work as well if programming failed
try to restart it from the very
beginning also these instructions can be
different for various car models
so be sure to follow the instructions
that came with your particular
programming device
alright guys that's pretty much it once
again if you want to know where i got
this programming kit from
check out the links in the description
area below i hope this video was helpful
and if so please give it a like
if not give it two dislikes thank you
for watching and have a nice day